on december the 8th the browns and the
bengals were playing in cleveland and we
found out the day after the game the
patriots had videotaped the sideline of
the bengals which was significant
because the patriots played the bengals
the following sunday the patriots
quickly admitted to an inadvertent
violation with no connection between the
video crew and football operations the
league began an investigation
and the investigation still continues to
this day the commissioner addressed it
at his pre-super bowl press conference
on january 29 he said they were still
looking at everything and i was told
yesterday by the league the matter
remains under review and the reason that
it's relevant if you're gonna take away
draft picks for the patriots
you probably should wrap it up and take
away the draft picks because the draft
is next week so this one is strange to
me why it is still lingering i was told
early on that some of the league office
were trying their damnedest to show that
there was a connection between the video
crew and football operations i don't
think it should be all that difficult to
get to the bottom of it with cell phone
records text messages emails whatever if
there's any overlap then they're busted
if there's no overlap then they're clean
and they just pay a fine i'm kind of
surprised it's taken what three and a
half months to get to this point and
they still don't have an answer big cat
do you think there's an element that the
league just doesn't really know what to
do because it's in that weird gray area
so they're kind of sitting on their
hands here and hoping that it goes away
or people like you stop asking which you
won't i know you you will not stop
asking you'll ask in five years what's
going on i know but but why not that's
what i do but that's what but why would
you but why would you act like that's a
bad thing that's what we do i know what
the hell is wrong with you why did i
miss you being on the show
no no listen you're listen don't get in
your feelings i'm just saying
do you think there's an element where
they're like we can probably wait out
everyone but florio that you know
annoying little net that keeps flying by
our ear and asking us what's going on
i i just think at some point they have
to do something the patriots know
they're going to get a punishment the
patriots hope it's only going to be a
fine and they're not going to lose draft
picks so it's just odd to me that this
thing still lingers but it's not like
the league makes these open issues a
huge priority antonio brown
he's still got an open investigation
that began in september for a violation
of the personal conduct policy so that's
crazy yeah when when when there are no
deadlines
externally you can take however much
time you want to do whatever you want to
do and address it whenever you feel like
addressing it and if no one is banging
on your door to provide an answer then
you can just let it sit and they
probably don't like being asked about it
because they prefer to let it sit big
cat
yeah they do and i think there is that
if they wait it out people will stop
thinking about it people will stop being
like hey what's going on here uh but we
have mike florio to thank cause he's
gonna keep beating down the drum i do
it is what you i'm being i'm you
actually but you act but you you find a
way to make it derisive
just a little twist of the night i
forgot here's here's the truth of it is
if you had told me that this had already
been resolved i would have said yes
because i didn't i hadn't thought about
it ever so you are you are the
collective uh memory of america no no i
forgot about it too i did a mailbag
yesterday podcast and somebody asked me
about it's like that's a good question
i'll go find the answer because i
thought it was over as well this hour's
over we'll be back for it after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports